Hi.
I'm Chet Haase, an engineer on
the Android team at Google.
I work on graphics
and animation.
And today, I want to talk
about some animation
capabilities of drawables.
Specifically, I want to talk
about KeyFrame Animations
using the class transition
drawable.
This is a way of specifying not
only what image is going
to be displayed at any given
time, but how long you're
going to display it before
displaying the next in a
sequence of drawables
you've actually
loaded into this thing.
So let's take a look
at the demo.
It's a fascinating demo where
we see a gray rectangle with
some text on top.
When I click on this, it's going
to start running this
animation with the drawables
that I've preloaded.
So click on it.
We see frame 0, 1,
2, 3, all that.
Click on it.
It stops.
A very exciting application.
It's a little more interesting
in code.
So why don't we take
a look at that now.
So we see this class
called KeyFrame
Animation that I created.
And there's an image view in
here, which is centered in
there, where we load
in these drawables.
So we create an animation
drawable object, where we're
going to load these things.
And for each of these, we're
going to add a frame.
So basically to create this
KeyFrame Animation, you're
going to keep adding
frames to it.
And this represents the series
of images that it's going to
animate between.
So we addFrame, calling
getDrawable for frame number.
And we pass in I. So basically
I'm just creating these simple
drawable images that have the
number embedded in them.
There's some code down here to
show you how I did that.
So we just create a bitmap of
a certain hard-coded size.
We have canvas.
We draw this grey
color into it.
And then we draw the text into
it, at an appropriate place,
and then return a
bitmap drawable,
based on that bitmap.
So for each one of those, we add
a frame to the animation
drawable, set one
shot default.
So we're just going to repeat
this infinitely until the
thing gets clicked on again.
We're going to set this
as the image drawable
on that image view.
And then we're going to have a
click listener and listen for
the user to actually
click the image.
And then we'll start the
animation running or stop it.
So when they click, if the
animation is already running,
we're going to call stop.
Otherwise, we're going
to call start.
Fairly straightforward.
I'm not doing anything
interesting here.
If you had something like an
image resource, with actual
timings embedded in the
metadata, then you could
create an animation drawable
to mimic that exactly.
Here, I'm just using the same
hard-coded 300 milliseconds to
animate and move on to the
next image in sequence.
And that's it for animation
drawable.
Thanks for tuning in.